Sour Patch Kid sucks
oh yeah why is that why is it because
you can't handle it it just sucks
because it's too intense why do I want
to overcome a candy in order to enjoy it
you don't need to overcome it without
you putting them in your mouth and going
oh Nobody Does that when they put them
in their mouth Nobody Does it no stop it
oh that was a wild ride you want to know
why you like Sour Patch Kids you want a
candy that matches your attitude I
sprayed lemon lice on my bathroom it
doesn't mean that if I ate poop I would
think it was lemon
look at a bowl of Skittles and I almost
I
you'd have to put you'd have to tie me
down for me to not just slam my head
into a bowl of Skittles like an ostrich
into the dirt but no it's funny what's
the matter with you loose candies is fun
what is the matter with you